-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
President Biden spoke from the
White House on Tuesday
and asked when the country
will be ready to
stand up to the gun lobby.
When we will?
That's like your landlord
saying,
"Ooh, you got to do
something about these mice."
[ Laughter ]
The White House announced -- has
announced that the K-Pop group
BTS will appear next week
with President Biden
because the White House
is always looking for ways
to make Biden look even older.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at that.
That's like a Korean
remake of "Scooby Doo."
[ Laughter ]
"I would have gotten away with
it if it weren't for
these pesky kids
and their catchy hooks."
[ Laughter ]
Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker
said in a new interview that
he's never heard
former President Trump say
that the 2020 election
was stolen from him.
Even more troubling,
he also said,
"Who is this Herschel Walker
I keep hearing about?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Herschel Walker said that he's
never heard Trump say
that the 2020 election
was stolen,
which is kind of like saying
you've never heard
Flo talk about Progressive.
[ Laughter ]
I've never heard her talk about
anything else.
Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene
won this week's
Republican primary
in Georgia's
14th Congressional district.
But just for fun, she's going
to storm the Capitol anyway.
[ Laughter ]
It's a celebration storm!
MSNBC announced this week
that former White House
Press Secretary Jen Psaki will
host a new streaming show.
Well, let's hope
"White House to NBC"
goes better than
"NBC to the White House."
[ Laughter ]
A romance novelist --
alright.
[ Laughter ]
No one rememb--
I don't remember
what show that was.
It could've been on any
network.
[ Laughter ]
A romance novelist in Oregon
who wrote a book -- excuse me.
who wrote a blog post titled
"How to Murder Your Husband"
was convicted yesterday
of killing her husband.
[ Laughter ]
In case you're wondering how far
you have to go to get someone
to read a blog post.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
41% of Americans
said that their largest single
monthly expense
is rent or mortgage,
and one said dinosaur skulls.
[ Laughter ]
Amtrak this week released
pictures of its new
Acela trains, which will feature
contactless restrooms.
Well, contactless
depending on your balance.
[ Laughter ]
Walking down one of those
is like
walking down
an old rope bridge.
[ Light laughter ]
And finally a plaster cast
of the late singer
Jimi Hendrix's penis is set to
be unveiled next month
at the phallological museum
in Iceland,
which houses the world's largest
display of penises.
It costs adults
10 bucks to enter,
while members get in free.
[ Laughter ]
He wrote --
he writes in my voice.
That's what I like about him.
You guys,
that was the monologue.
How are you feeling?
[ Cheers and applause ]